our speaker today is Gordon Moore who is
chairman of the board of Intel
Corporation a uh a major supplier of
microprocessors and other useful things
and he's going to talk today about vlsi
industry trends technology technological
and economic Gordon
okay well thank you I'll hide over here
behind the lectern to get up from the
way of my own slides
this year the integrated circuit is 30
years old it's old enough that I read in
the paper last week that TI is getting
their patent issued in Japan finally
uh in I am
repeatedly amazed at what we can design
and build you know I've
been involved in this industry since the
beginning of the integrated circuit in
fact before that but not long ago I
would have had a difficult time
accepting the fact that we could either
design a million transistor circuit
covering a chip maybe a half a square
inch
or that if we were able to design it
that we'd be able to make it
now we not only expect to be able to
make such things but we expect to be
able to make them so they work the first
time
we've really come a tremendous way in
this 30 years
and uh I think it's fair and perhaps
appropriate to ask is the technology
getting anywhere near saturation that is
are we going to be able to continue the
progress we've made in designing and
making the integrated circuits as the
technology becomes fully developed
and we could ask where is the technology
likely to go technically or
geographically I suppose
and even what drives it so today what
I'm going to do
is stand back and take the 20 or 30-year
view of what's been going on in the
industry and try to make some broad
extrapolations and hopefully draw some
conclusions about what is happening what
has happened and therefore maybe we can
figure out what might happen in the
future
first
I think it's useful to sit back and say
what's made this technology so powerful
already
clearly it has had a very important
impact and has been able to evolve
rapidly for 30 years or more
and I think the reason this has happened
is we've been exploiting a violation of
Murphy's Law
by making things smaller
everything gets better simultaneously
essentially you don't trade anything off
you know the things get faster the
electrons don't have so far to move
uh clearly we can cut the power
consumption
uh
the systems made become more reliable
because we can go to higher levels of
integration on a given silicon chip and
we've been able to keep the right
reliability per silicon chip at least
constant irrespective of what we stick
on the chip
but most important as we've progressed
along higher levels of integration we've
been able to make things cheaper
now the cost of doing things
electronically in the 30 years since the
invention of the integrated circuit has
dropped a million fold in many cases
the easiest place to see that is you can
buy a megabit dram today for less than
Fairchild sold its first individual
silicon transistors for 35 years ago
I remember those first transistors we
sold them for 150 a piece
now a megabit dram that not only
includes well over a million transistors
but all the circuit design and
interconnections that go along with
itself are far less than
the same
thing is the individual transistor
I've often used an analogy about this
you know what would have happened if the
Auto industry had Advanced that rapidly
during these last 30 years and you come
to the conclusion you know a million
mile an hour the half a million miles to
the gallon of gas
it would be cheaper to throw away your
Rolls-Royce and buy a new one to the
park at downtown for the evening
but of course you wouldn't have to throw
it away it's reliability would be such
you would you could pass it on for
several Generations well I thought this
was pretty good though one time somebody
in the audience pointed out to me it'd
only be two inches long and a half inch
high it wouldn't be much good for my
morning commute
but
I think as you look at an industry
that's decreased the cost of its product
a million fold
what one characteristic does that
industry have to have
it has to sell a heck of a lot more of
them at the end of that time than it did
in the beginning
uh
the
we clearly have to sell a lot more than
a million times as many transistors
today as we did
30 years ago to make up for this so I
think that's the slide I'd like to start
with in a lot of respect it's going to
be the most important slide I have
concerning what's been required to make
this industry go
and that is
my curve of Market elasticity
and I'm going to generally be looking at
the same time scale as we go through the
various slides about the the last 20
years which coincidentally matches
Intel's history we were formed in 68
but
if you look at this estimate of the
total number of transistors produced in
the world
uh you see that it is on a curve that
goes up a factor of 10 about every three
years for the average slope in there
a factor of 10 every three years if it
if it doubled every year would be a
factor of eight in three years so
the amount of transistors the industry
build more than doubles every year
you know all know the nature of a series
that does that it means that during this
year we will build more electronic
function than existed in the world on
January 1st
it's a phenomenally elastic Market more
elastic than any other one I've ever
been able to see
now I got a little chicken on the slope
up here in the upper end because frankly
it gets increasingly hard to identify
applications that use 10 to the 15th
transistors per year
you know that's a million transistors
for every man woman and child in the
developed world
it is really a phenomenal amount of
electronics and I think you people have
probably all used your million
transistors and then some this year
but uh you have to look forward to
2 million next year
four or five million the year after and
so forth and you have to bring all your
friends from the liberal arts division
along with you if we're going to keep on
this curve
uh I used to have a difficult time
generating points for this I had to go
down through all the products made
estimate how many transistors they had
and add them up and it probably could
get precise within a factor of two in
recent years all they have to do is
count the number of dram bits and
multiply that by two and I went within a
factor of two it turns out it's gotten
easier rather than more difficult as
time has gone on
well let's look at a few other trends a
one that we alluded to earlier is the
fact that we continually make smaller
and smaller structures
this has been on a quite good
exponential curve with a slope of about
a factor of two every six years and
actually I could actually extrapolate
that back another decade and it would
still be on the same slope
every six years we can cut our minimum
dimensions in half
and it is continued without any real
sign of saturation now saturation has
been predicted in this curve about every
two years for the last the decade or
more you know we didn't think we'd get
anywhere's near a micron optically
but uh in fact we not only got to a
micron we now expect to use Optical
lithography techniques to at least do a
half a micron and probably to three
tenths of a micron and clearly well
beyond my retirement
uh it is amazing how this limit has
continued to recede as we've pushed
further and further
to make the smaller structures
we've decreased structures
a hundred fold in Dimensions without yet
approaching any kind of a fundamental
limit
there's some indication that maybe
around a tenth of a micron for minimum
structures we'll start to see some
effects that will make life more
difficult but for the time being at
least we think we're on this track of
continuing to make things smaller
without any real problems
in the other direction
we've had a similar Trend toward making
structures thinner
in a lot of respects this one surprises
me significantly more than the narrower
lines
I expected we'd be getting insignificant
problems when we got the film
thicknesses of the order of a thousand
angstroms I felt that 20 years ago at
least
because on the back of an envelope you
can convince yourself that if these
films come down as statistical piles of
atoms that you start to see huge
variations in the thickness
when you got down to that kind of a
range so the electrical properties
wouldn't behave well
but this clearly hasn't happened
working on down to films below 100
angstroms and thickness I got a little
aggressive on the curve out here at the
tail end we don't work much below 100
angstroms these days where you only have
the order of 10 Atomic layers these
things still behave beautifully no signs
of the kind of statistical holes that I
thought we were going to get clearly
it's not a random phenomenon the forces
on our side chemical forces in uh this
instance and these things actually tend
to work in our favor rather than against
us again we're trifling with Murphy I
think and the way this goes here though
we actually are approaching a limit and
on these thin films we're down at the
point where we can actually see quantum
mechanical tunneling through them
instead of that being a problem so far
we've exploited it in some of the
electrically
erasable memories but we can't expect to
go an awful lot further on that
particular limit because we're actually
starting to reach a fundamental
limitation
taking another cut at it we can look at
the charge necessary to separate a one
or a zero in several generations of
eproms in this case
it's unusual you know I count
transistors by saying 10 to the 15th I
count charge by saying a hundred
thousand electrons
this is the opposite way we would have
talked about things 20 or 30 years ago
where charges that we dealt with were 10
to the 15th electrons and uh
the number of transistors were down in
reasonable numbers but here again we
have a a trend that has remained quite
constant we cut the charge about a
factor of two every generation of memory
products and show a little sign of it
rounding off now we we're up to the four
megabit the eproms these days and I'll
admit I didn't update my curve to see if
we're still on this but I'm sure we're
well under a hundred thousand electrons
on the stored charged and in spite of
that we still expect to get a hundred
year retention of this kind of a memory
uh longer than we ever would have
committed a decade or more ago
let's take another one of these let's
take drams
and here
here the world hasn't been quite so
uh uniform we were coming down the same
kind of a curve until the 64 k d Ram
when all of a sudden we ran into a
problem
the memories were forgetting a bit now
and then
big systems built out of the initial 64k
drams tend to make soft errors
non-repeatable loss of data in the
memory
and this was tracked down
after rather extensive investigations to
being the result of residual alpha
particles coming out of the packaging
material
one alpha particle made enough whole
electron pairs that could actually erase
the data in a dram bit
of course there are a lot of solutions
to that one is to clean up your
packaging materials to cut the incidence
of alpha particles another is to try to
put some kind of a layer on there that
absorbs some
those things were done but in addition
we had to Jack the number of electrons
back up so they were not sensitive to a
single alpha particle error
and now it's flattened out at around a
million a million electrons necessary to
be sure you're not going to get a
problem from a single alpha particle
this is the one place I can identify
where we've actually run across some
kind of a relatively fundamental limit
that we had to lead live with
it's also the reason that the dram
technologies have gotten so darn complex
uh you can't continue to scale the
capacitors as time goes on you have to
go in there and figure out how to get
enough capacitance in the small areas so
people are going to three-dimensional
structures with deep trenches into the
silicon and things like that in order to
get a capacitor sufficient area to get
your million electrons on there so we
have alpha particle
insensitivity I think had it been any
product except drams which is the Macho
product for the semiconductor industry
we would have relaxed and enjoyed the
technology we had available and stopped
at a much lower density than we're still
fighting to achieve on the new products
today
well it's turned in a slightly different
direction
and look at another technological Trend
and this is what's happened to our
defects during this time period
this is a very important change in that
we've finally worked ourselves out of a
rut
we used to develop a technology stick it
into manufacturing at relatively low
yield or relatively High defect density
massage the process and the product
until we got higher yields just about
the time we were doing pretty well you
know 20 30 percent yield we'd find we
got an economic Advantage by scaling the
geometry
which redefines the defect smaller ones
now affect you going back in again at
high defect densities and low yields and
working ourselves around that Loop made
a lot of progress that way but we were
changing generations of Technology as
fast as we were decreasing defects so we
didn't make any real progress for a
while the last couple of generations
we've broken out of that we're starting
at lower defect densities and taking
them down to much lower defect densities
and this of course has significant
implications on what the designer can
consider in terms of Chip size and so
forth we can make very much larger
devices today than we used to in fact
today it is
an occasional event at least to see a
perfect wafer that is one where every
circuit on it is good
I have Intel's first 100 percent yield
wafer hanging on my office wall
I've heard rumors of competitors having
100 percent yield runs where every wafer
in the run with 100 yield I'll have to
admit I've yet to see one of those but
100 yield Wafers are something that
would be hard to conceive of looking
back at say the mid 70s so a tremendous
amount of progress has been made there
and I think it really means we can
seriously consider things like wafer
scale integration where the whole wafer
is built into a system should there be
another good reason for doing that
as a result our chip sizes can get
bigger
and they've grown about an order of
magnitude an area over Intel's history
as well as increasing a thousand times
or more in complexity during this time
period so we now have
in a loud range of product complexity
and here I'm really on memories thinking
logic circuits for example where you can
make anything you want that falls in
that red area
so million transistor kind of logic
circuits now are straightforward to do
in fact we've introduced a few of them
this year the Next Generation staying on
this curve we'll look at four or five
million transistors in the next
generation of microprocessors
and I don't see why we ought to be
falling off this curve and you
extrapolate this to the year 2000
you conclude that we can be looking at a
logic circuit with something in the 50
to 100 million transistors on it they
actually extrapolates closer to 100 than
it does to 50.
I don't quite know what to do with a
hundred million transistors worth of
logic on a chip yet I think every logic
function we've ever built could be put
on one chip with this level of
complexity
and I think it really
is a challenge
to figure out what to do with it
but this challenge is not new
I picked the slide here
uh which I have on its side but you can
rotate at 90 degrees this shows the
design effort
versus time to make the state-of-the-art
logic chips over a period of time and
actually use this slide in a solid state
circus conference keynote address I
think in 1979 showing that we were
having the problem where the cost of
Designing these things was absolutely
skyrocketing on us and something that we
weren't going to be able to continue to
live with
because the investment was going up so
dramatically
in fact at that time and actually for
someone longer than this slide shows
this curve should have come out here a
ways before it fell down
it was taking about a constant effort
per transistor in the completed circuit
to design it this is kind of the
hardware equivalent of the productivity
of a programmer being so many lines of
code irrespective of the time we had the
same kind of a problem in the hardware
area we get about the same number of
transistors designed per day per person
involved in the design
now this was still pretty darn good this
took a lot of computer age and one thing
another to stay at that because it would
be easy to imagine the design effort
would go up with some power function of
the number of transistors
but with Cad and systematic Design
Technology we've been able to overcome
this now and get to the point where
we're only a slowly growing size design
team we can make increasingly complex
integrated circuits
this really lets us use this
processing technology that I showed in
the the previous slide so we can
actually fill that entire red area
on product complexity
well moving in another Direction
and this one of all the slides I'm
showing doesn't have real data in it
it's just my guess what's happening
that's the growth in the number of
different semiconductor products
with the Asic technology that's gotten
pretty widely distributed and a lot of
system designers making their own
circuits now we've had an explosion in
the different
functions that are out there
this has a lot of implications for the
manufacturer it means each one of these
can't be considered a separate product
and put through its own separate
reliability testing for example because
there just is not enough capability to
handle that we have to qualify
generically the process
similarly the designs have to work the
first time so we have to kind of qualify
the design technology rather than go
through and exhaustively
try to test each of the products that
comes out
I think it's a real control problem and
one that has a significant impact in the
industry although less impact directly
on the users than do a variety of others
moving to another Trend you know get
down to the processing technology
our processes have continued to grow in
complexity when I look at this it's hard
to realize that the principal
initial argument for MOS over bipolar
was a greater process Simplicity it only
used four masking steps instead of six
we've sure succeeded in changing that
over the years here I picked some eprom
processes here on this particular curve
we're getting to the point now where new
processes are of the order of 20 masking
steps the new dram processes are in that
level of complexity also the logic
processes with three layers of
interconnections tend to be in the High
Teens
we really have succeeded in making this
a lot more complex and of course masking
steps are only a good proxy for the
total process complexity each of these
usually requires a deposition a masking
and etching some kind of a heat
treatment probably a half a dozen or
more major process steps for each mask
these things have gotten tremendously
complex but even during this the defect
density has dropped dramatically
what it gets tied to though is a
tremendous increase in the cost of
developing another generation of process
and this actually was the Intel data in
68 we started out we developed two major
new processes as well as our initial
products and put them in production for
less than three million dollars
our latest process of the order of 60
million dollars to develop and get
running in production
the one difference here is that the I'm
now including some of the engineering
necessary to get through high yields
looking at that curve would anybody want
to guess when the Japanese started to
become important in this business
you're right it's right there at the
knee of the curves
it really took off
and
it has gotten exceedingly difficult
to get a leadership position in the
industry based on the processing
technology
this is kind of qualitative data also
but if you assume that the industry
leaders
the people that generally have the top
products out there you know they say the
half dozen companies that are more or
less parallel in technology at any time
spend one unit on getting their position
if you wanted to try to get a year ahead
of that
we estimate it would take probably three
times that expenditure to do just to
pull everything in that far
you know there you have to develop a
large portion of your own equipment you
have a lot of additional loads that you
take on yourself that don't exist if
you're going along generally with the
Leading Edge the net result is nobody
has a Year's lead anymore in General on
the technology maybe on some particular
part of it where they've invented a new
structure but not in the mainstream
technology
uh and if you want to lag behind a
couple of years you can do it very
cheaply you can pick up what other
people did and that's been a viable uh
strategy for some of the companies in
there
but the point here is that where a major
portion of the industry's advantage used
to be in sustaining some kind of a
technological advantage in the
processing that has gotten very very
difficult to do and it's hard to see any
sustainable Advantage there anymore so
increasingly we try to be competitive on
the processing technology and get our
advantage in the product design in order
to maintain a really viable business
well other parts of the uh
business have gotten more expensive also
for example if we look at the cost of
various pieces of equipment these are
several major pieces of equipment you
see their costs have grown roughly on
the exponential scale during this time
period also when Intel started in 68 a
given piece of equipment cost about
twelve thousand dollars you could buy a
lithography machine or a bank of
furnaces or sputter or it was around ten
or twelve thousand dollars
in the one micron generation it was
closer to 1.2 million dollars it had
gone up a hundred fold in the cost of a
piece of equipment in the Next
Generation we're looking at pieces of
equipment that individually cost two to
three million dollars in several cases
now
the discouraging part of this is the
throughput of these pieces of equipment
is about the same in 1968 is in 1988.
they still get their 20 Wafers per hour
through whatever the nominal number is
the only real difference in the output
is that the Wafers are bigger than they
used to be
so
the cost of the equipment is growing
dramatically so the business has become
a lot more Capital intensive during this
time period than it was two decades ago
a significant semiconductor plant now
one to make volume products cost about
as much as a significant steel mill
uh
our Albuquerque plant which is four
different processing modules by the time
it's filled will cost well over 600
million dollars for the building plus
the equipment it contains I say well
over because the last couple of modules
aren't yet committed and each one is
sequentially costing quite a bit more
than the previous one
uh the next result is uh if you look at
the cost of a facility
uh
that is reasonably well balanced for a
production point of view this is the
cost of capital to process about a
thousand waivers a week
a minimum balance facility that is where
one piece of equipment isn't kept
waiting because it has more capacity
than the other is probably a couple of
thousand wafer starts a week so a
reasonably competitive manufacturing
facility has to have about a hundred
million dollars worth of equipment in it
at the current generations of the eight
tenths Micron generation is just moving
on into production and would probably
have more than that to get better
utilization
if anything the half Micron generation
is significantly understated in
this curve
so you know the first thing you see
thing now Capital intensity of this was
that this is clearly not a business for
startups
so we look at the new Semiconductor
Company formations over this time period
and we see well it may not be a business
for startups the people that Finance
startups didn't realize this during most
of this time period
by the way this curve has some other
interesting things on it it shows you
the dates of the changes in the tax law
uh this was this was the introduction of
the 1969 tax law which is significant
increase on capital gains tax
uh there was the 79 tax law change that
decreased the capital gains tax and then
it came back again uh in the 80s it
probably understated here at this end
because you don't pick up all of the
startups in something like this because
some of them are invisible for a few
years before they're picked up so in
spite of this Capital intensity we had a
huge increase in the number of
semiconductor startups in fact we can
integrate that I'm just out of phase
with the lights I see and this is a
pretty good measure of the total number
of semiconductor companies in the world
it did a little bit more than integrated
that I added in the foreign companies
but in this curve they don't make much
difference because they're lost in the
noise of all the U.S companies and I
accounted for some of the ones that went
out of business or were combined with
others so we have an industry here that
has something over 200 companies
involved in it most of them U.S
companies
and something like that is clearly a
highly fractionated business you might
think
but if you look at it another way
you see that in fact the business has
done principally by a relatively few
companies
uh here I took MOS LSI instead of the
total semiconductor industry they're not
very different in this curve but you see
that something approaching 70 percent of
the dollars say two-thirds of the the
business is done by the top 10 companies
and uh 30 percent of it is actually done
by about the top three
so you have an industry here
that has a lot of little companies
a few medium-sized companies and a very
few very large companies so it looks
like an industry
viewed at this level that is dominated
by this 10 very big companies well
that's fine except
if you look one step
different and look at the 10 companies
the thing you see is they're not the
same 10.
now this is color coded on this Slide
the blue companies are us-based the red
companies are Japanese based and the
green company
is other
uh of course the the trend you see here
is the graph where the table gets a lot
redder as you go to the right
uh
and you might think this is terrible
performance on the part of the U.S
industry well it take a particular
example or let's take Texas Instruments
for example they went from 65 million to
238 to 572 to 1 billion 271 million in
Revenue during this time period now this
is really a growth
that most companies would be extremely
happy to have growing what's that
20-fold over the 20 years you know
unprecedented in most other Industries
it was good enough to go from first
place to eighth place in this case
in these five-year periods with one
minor exception the 10th largest company
is bigger than the largest one was five
years previously
so it's been a phenomenal growth
industry
but the real rapid Growers have turned
out to be the Japanese companies
now I expect that this will continue to
change because there are a lot of other
people who are trying to get in to the
1993 version of that
uh
you know we have uh at least three major
Korean companies that are aggressively
pursuing this I suspect in fact Samsung
will be in the top 10 if not next year
the year after certainly by the 1993
update I do with this plot you got
companies like Phillips and Siemens in
Europe who are strongly dedicated to a
major position in the semiconductor
industry
uh you have new entries coming in from
some of the developing countries Taiwan
is aggressively going after this
business so I think we're going to
continue to see a lot of changes of the
players in this top ten and those of us
who are there don't want to get pushed
out very easily
so this has been a broad overall view of
some of the trends in the semiconductor
industry
you know we looked at some that were
technical some that were financial and
some that are structural
uh I think overall it was something that
really has shown phenomenal progress
over this period of time in fact it's
unprecedented in its rate of change as
near as I can see
you know the million fold plus decrease
in the cost combined with the fact that
a technology
that didn't even exist when most of you
were born has become so important
in this 20-year period
it's really been an exciting roller
coaster ride but might take a look at uh
what it's going to take to keep it going
like this and I kind of see three things
here we have to worry about
one of them
I'll call driving the machine
you know uh
this business and its rapid growth
continue to depend on the market
expansion in order to be able to afford
the investment to keep the technology
moving
you really have to look if you used your
million transistorship this year this is
the the question it comes down to where
do we find applications for 10 to the
16th transistors a year or 10 to the
17th transistors a year so how can we
use as much electronic function
uh I think we can wave our hands and see
some things that could produce uh the
kind of requirements we're after there
uh you know the real-time speech
recognition is one of my favorites so I
can talk to my P3 instead of having to
fumble over the keyboard that can use
more bits and mips and about anything I
can think of but those are the kinds of
things you have to have you
in order to use these huge numbers of
electronic functions you kind of have to
come up with an application that you can
multiply by the population of the world
or by the number of households in the
world or something like that it can't be
something that the
you know it sits one per major
university and have any real impact on
keeping the industry driving through
these very high volume applications and
I will admit I am having trouble seeing
the applications that are going to
consume the vast amount of electronics
we have to make
but that shouldn't bother you I've
always had trouble figuring out who was
going to use all of these things
uh I gave a talk a decade ago roughly
essentially that was the the
subject of the talk who's going to use
all these functions well I thought I was
talking to a technical audience it
turned out there was some security
analysts in the crowd and they got very
concerned you know the last thing you
want to tell a security analyst is no
what are you going to do with all the
product you're going to make
so I
I got the job of having to answer that
question for the security community at a
subsequent talk
so using the same kind of argument you
needed something you could multiply by a
big number like the number of people or
number of households I decided I'd take
my house as an example
it had walked through the house room by
room and try to identify every
application I could think of for a
microprocessor this was
77.78 to kind of that time period And I
went through there you look at every
light switch and yeah I could use a
timer in there like use that in the
washing machine and so forth I think I
identified 80 some 85 or 87 I forget
which possible applications for
microprocessor in my house
well I can go through there now and I
don't have that many but I'm sure there
are several tens of microprocessors
and well over half of them are used for
applications I never thought of when I
went through
only that long ago
uh
these low-cost functions create a lot of
their own applications and I hope we can
find some more that are of the size of
the PC in order to keep driving us along
this exponential but the nature of
exponentials are such that you always
fall off of them
any of these extrapolations of an
exponential produces a disaster I
remember as a student the extrapolation
of the growth of the population of the
world you know the pretty soon you have
one person for every square yard and
every square feet and then you go 3D and
you know where is there really a limit
and finally one of the physicists in the
audience said the one limit he could
think of is when you had a ball of
humanity with the periphery expanding
with the speed of light
and it turns out you don't even have to
extrapolate very far into the future to
get to that point when you pick an
exponential like that so we are going to
fall off of this one before too long I'm
sure
anyhow at this stage of the game it's
easier for me to extrapolate the
technology this is going to serve these
markets than it is to see these markets
for 10 to the six names or 10 to the 17
transistors per year
and I have a concern that when these
markets do occur they're going to happen
in Geographic areas where we don't have
as good an access to the market you know
we we can serve our U.S customers very
well our European customers pretty well
most of the Asian Rim quite well Japan
we have a tough time getting into and
that's a major part of the market so
there are problems for the industry
overall and some additional problems I
think for any uh particularly
geographically located company
next thing is
driving this machine is keeping the
wheels on that is not running across
anything that's going to really stop our
rate of evolution
uh I don't see anything happening here
but the kind of problem we ran into in
drams where something came along and bid
us that we didn't expect
now I've been expecting something like
this to come out of the blue for some
time I remember a paper published back
in the early 60s that predicted that the
reliability of electronics would start
to decrease when the active volumes got
smaller than about a cubic micron
the argument was that cosmic rays would
ruin material and over that kind of a
dimension and there are enough Cosmic
arrays coming in that this could be
significant now our active volumes are
well below a cubic Micron of these
devices we haven't gotten bitten yet so
that may have been a false prediction
I'll admit I haven't gone back to read
the article to see if I could find a
flaw in it or not but something like
that is likely to come along that will
significantly slow our rate of evolution
the other thing will be if we just can't
figure out what to do with the things it
is if the need for very complex
functions cannot be defined there I'll
have to depend on you people to see what
you can come up with the third one
is the cost of this business
it's frankly very expensive and getting
more expensive
I'm sure this is more my problem to
worry about than yours
but
we have competitors who are getting very
heavy subsidies combined with very
focused activities to become major
participants in this business
and these make the future of the U.S
industry less certain that I'd like to
see it to be
the cost of capital in the U.S is a lot
higher than it is particularly in Japan
the availability is less and
the patients associated with that is
probably somewhat less
so anyhow to summarize I think
technologically we're okay we kind of
see where that's going
the industry structure is going to
continue to change we'll get different
players in these five-year updates of
who the biggest companies are and who
the leaders are that's something that
happens in any area where the evolution
is fairly rapid it's hard to lock in a
position for very long
Europe and Korea each have two or three
companies that aspire to be in the top
ten
to say nothing of the U.S and
you know that other 190 U.S companies
that are on there they all hope to get
there too
so there's going to be continued push to
get dominant positions there
the markets are going to change in the
world you know Europe is either going to
be more open or more closed depending on
who you talk to with the changes from
1992 and Lord knows the changes of the
last few weeks with looking in Eastern
Europe are certainly going to have a
tremendous influence in the way this
industry and a lot of the rest of the
industries develop
Japan we keep hoping will implement the
intent of the trade agreement we have
with them that's going to open their
markets the U.S semiconductors that's
happening very slowly making a little
bit of progress
and anyhow it's a game for well-financed
companies and governments in particular
but the important thing I want to leave
you with is the market must continue to
expand if we're going to maintain the
spectacular rate of progress we've
become accustomed to and you can do more
to help that than I can certainly
and I'd be happy to take questions on
anything that relates to the industry in
general as well as what I've talked
about here specifically
yes
do I have to repeat the questions here
okay the question I realized what do I
think of the future of optical chips I
think there are
several very specific places uh where
you know they're clearly going to be
important connecting things optically is
just a marvelous way to do it there's no
ground loops and
you get rid of a lot of problems I am a
skeptic about Optical Computing where
you do much stuff on chip optically
uh I don't really see the advantages as
being that great and I see the
technology as being darn tough to get to
you're competing with a very
well-developed way of doing things when
you you try to bring Optics on the chip
uh you get away from Silicon which is a
very comfortable material in order to do
the optical emitters anyhow
I am inclined to think it's going to
perform the peripheral interconnection
functions but it's not going to be that
important in the main body of the
computing
yes when you were doing your financial
numbers were any of those adjusted for
inflation or were those all in real
dollars at the time they were
representing those are all in real
dollars these things are changing so
fast it doesn't make a lot of difference
if you do adjust them for inflation you
know you maybe you get a factor of two
out of there but when you're talking two
orders of magnitude the the
qualitatively the data is the same so I
just used dollars at the current at the
time they were spent
question yes what do you see as the
future of the specific Hardware or or
what's on the chip I mean do you think
we'll see more parallelism uh you know a
little a bunch of little CPUs on there
together or what's going to be on the
chips themselves well
uh
you know clearly we're going to see
those kinds of things
we stick a lot of
the parallelism on now and as the
software is capable of using it will put
a lot more
now we have uh
uh we announced a microcontroller this
year that has two separate risks
execution units and the the logic to
apportion a job to the one that's not
busy and so forth the we can handle that
kind of thing
a thing like a 386 essentially has a 286
built in the corner in order to execute
the things that were written for the
286. you know it it only takes a small
portion of the chip one of the uh 16-bit
processor takes 20 000 transistors
you'll be working with a million
transistor budget so I use two percent
of the transistors to do that
uh
oh one of our new Chips uh you know has
a risk processor floating Point Adder
floating Point multiplier graphic
subunit and you fill the rest of the
chip with static memory for a cash to
speed up the operation of the whole
thing so you we can put as much on there
as we can think of the the software and
the system requirement to use and our
recent processor design tends to be put
as much function on as you can think of
and fill the rest up with cache memory
I'd hate to think though that our
million transistors or 100 million
transistor chips are going to be little
processors with several megabytes the
cache memory I think that would be a a
very poor use of the technology uh
compared with what would theoretically
be possible if we can think of the right
functions yeah the U.S is pretty well
dropped dram production to a very small
level do you think that's going to
continue or do you think that we'll get
back into the dram business and start
competing actively with the Far East
vendors well
the industry is trying to make a
significant entry into the dram business
a thing called U.S memories which you
may have read about in the newspaper the
users of drams got very concerned last
year about the lack of U.S sources for
drams they found themselves the
getting drams from their Japanese
systems competitors the Japanese
companies are all vertically integrated
the same ones that make drams make
computers
and the U.S suppliers couldn't get the
number they wanted and had to pay a lot
more money than they wanted to so they
were very concerned in 88 about a USD
Ram Supply so the semiconductor industry
which is not very interested in going
back in the dram business in general
because
the competitive situation isn't very
attractive there for us decided early
this year that we would try to solve our
customers problems and
a group of companies have sponsored
trying to set up U.S memories which
would be a major company
taking IBM technology IBM makes Dr amps
for internal use we take that technology
on a factory to factory transfer and
enter first at the four megabit dram
level and then at the 16 and subsequent
Generations
and we're trying to get the users to
step up and pay the entry fee for that
the entry fee is pretty high we want 550
million dollars in equity
and want to be able to borrow about the
same amount is it a huge
startup with the idea of getting very
rapidly up to speed well uh
we were looking to get this concluded by
the end of the year you either get
everybody put their money in or not
and some of the stories in the paper
recently have said that a few of the
companies it would be logical
participants like Apple computer for
example have opted not to do it and
unless we get almost all of those big
users in I don't think we're going to
have the muscle behind it to make it
happen and I'm actually going to get a
report on Friday from the guide that's
trying to get us started so I'm not as
up to date and that as I might be but I
give it no better than a 50 chance right
now of getting financed because this
year you can get all the drams you
wanted good prices
we have short memories unfortunately
will the markets in other Asian
countries
uh would you repeat that please
question was how do you view the markets
in connection with the three things to
keep it going you mentioned
yeah in the other other Asian countries
other than Japan
that's right uh the countries that are
getting very active in the PC uh for
example uh Taiwan in particular but uh
also Korea these markets are more open
to us uh
the
the Taiwan Hong Kong Singapore we have
as good access to with anybody
they are certainly turning out a lot of
product so far it tends to be
duplicative you know it's kind of clones
what's being turned out other places
they haven't really taken an initiative
to develop new applications they have
extended the market though by getting
the prices now and on a lot of things
which is also important in getting
elasticity so we view that as very
important that's the the fastest growing
market area in the world for us right
now
yes yeah you mentioned the need for uh
semiconducting history of enormous
capital and especially Process Equipment
and also you mentioned the need for big
markets do you think there is a big
future for uh non-very vertically
integrated companies uh who want to be
players in the semiconductor industry
yeah and another question uh I'd like to
link it do a semiconductor industry
Executives in the US wish that the
federal government be more involved in
in the support of that industry
especially Investments okay uh in the
first case uh you know I clearly think
that non-vertically integrated
semiconductor companies have a position
we're vertically integrated to some
extent we have a small systems business
we're small compared with our
semiconductor business
uh in fact in the U.S the converse has
been true and that the only companies
that are survived in the semiconductor
business are ones that are principally
semiconductor companies where big
vertically integrated companies you know
the General Electrics the rcas and so
forth we're participants they found they
had areas that were less risky to make
their investment those of us who grew up
on semiconductors don't have a place to
run very easily so we're we're dedicated
to that business
now the second part of your question
about uh the U.S government
uh
we are anxious to have proper support
from the US government now proper
support as far as I am concerned
principally is one that the yeah to use
the cliche he keeps the playing field
level
uh if we're in a situation where the U.S
says we're not going to favor any
Industries we're not going to do
anything for any particular industry and
our trading partners say we want the
drams we want the VCR and they subsidize
Investments to pick those off I think
that's the dumbest thing we could do we
just sit there and let them have all the
industries they want so I think we're
we're competing with something other
than the regular economic forces we have
to have something that protects us from
that and Washington is not in general
agreement on that yet you know a little
help here and there but there are
ideologies represented back there that
says the free market will take care of
everything that's fine except the world
is not a free market
the U.S is the most accessible market
for a variety of reasons in the world
everybody comes after the U.S market
and when they do it with advantages that
we can't compete with I really think we
have to be concerned otherwise we're
likely to lose all of our industries of
the future and be stuck with some of the
ones of the past so we are actively
trying to get our government to
understand this problem from our point
of view
with varying success
yes what do you see is the major
challenges and opportunities for
improving the productivity and quality
of semiconductor Manufacturing
uh
first on equality that's an area where I
don't think there is a real problem
anymore you know the quality of our
devices the quality of the Japanese
devices in the eyes of the major users
are equivalent and we're continuing to
improve them
there's a lot that can be done yet in
improving the productivity of the
semiconductor industry that is the one
place
the Japanese really did a better job
than us they focused on manufacturing
early uh
they are still capable of doing a
variety of things we're not the they can
bring a plant up from a you know a bare
field to an operating plant a lot faster
than we can
uh for a variety of reasons you know
simple things like their construction
Crews work 24 hours seven days
where we get four and a half day
construction weeks so they can build a
plant a lot quicker they have a an
equipment supplier industry where when
you're installing the equipment you get
all the technicians and everything come
in with the equipment one plant over
there had 1200 people from the equipment
vendors working in it at the time the
plant was being brought up
we don't have that kind of capability
here so developing that sort of thing is
important and I think the there's
tremendous opportunities in the
manufacturing area in general that we
still have to address we're trying to
you know there's been a lot of emphasis
in getting manufacturing to be something
treated in the universities with some
success in that
I hope that we solve these problems
before we're put out of the
manufacturing businesses
yes Intel's had a lot of very successful
products through the years have there
been any dramatic failures that you'd
like to comment on and what were the
causes of such here's my 15 million
dollar watch
I keep this just in case we ever get an
idea going to another consumer product
business uh sure we've had uh failures
also we've had failures of commission
and failures of omission both
we just in the last couple of months
announced the shutdown of a joint
venture with Siemens Corporation for
example which was a major new computer
architecture
and a lot of advanced features built
into it but uh was you know a closed
computer system required a phenomenal
amount of software to get over the
threshold and the closer we got to it
the bigger the program became and the
further out in time the payoff was we
just decided we couldn't carry it
through to fruition
at one the watch was an example of
something where literally
I thought it was going to be a lot of
Technology leverage in there you know
the Silicon chip we made the display and
so forth when we got out of the business
the chip cost less than the little push
pins on the side of the case that are
used for setting it it wasn't the
technology business at all
at least at that time
for an error of Omission rather than
commission I turned down the idea for
the PC a couple of years before Apple
came into existence yes somebody came
around and described this thing and you
know the programmable device or a home
computer
the only application he could think of
was the housewife having her recipes
there which you know I picture my wife
in a computer in the kitchen I can't
imagine anything that seemed more remote
so I didn't appreciate you know the
person doing this couldn't Express
clearly what he felt that's often the
case with a new idea and in my
experience I couldn't translate what he
was saying to something that seemed
important to me so we missed it we
missed the engineering workstation for a
different reason we just never put the
resources on it we used to own the
engineering workstation Market because
we sold these development systems with
our microprocessors we dealt with the
right customer we had the right kind of
product and we had to keep all our
energy and getting that going we talked
about doing what has become the
engineering workstation we never got the
Manpower behind it to do it so we got
lots of examples of things we didn't do
right but we've done enough of them
right that we've grown to be a fairly
significant business in the meantime you
don't have to be right every time you've
got to be right enough of the times in
this business yes
what is your view about the analog vrsi
and what is the vision of the Intel N64
neural network chip
the
clearly analog functions are useful but
uh
most of the world seems to be digital in
the electronics field at least
I don't know quite where analog fits
into the very complex stuff you know we
tend to put an a to d converter on the
front end of something
but do everything digitally on the chip
it's the digital circuits that really
take advantage of the high degree of
complexity now which product did you ask
about specifically
foreign
64 neural network oh okay fine yeah that
is an idea of potentially a new market
uh
I guess that is an analog memory if you
look at it that way it's a weighting
function for neural networks we think
neural networks are a very interesting
alternative way to do Computing
particularly things like pattern
recognition where regular computers
don't do well and we want to at least
keep our finger in that and participate
we have the right technology to make a
particular product there we got a small
research group that's following up where
that whole field is going we hope
someday we can really pick some products
out of it right now it's you know it's
not at all clear how big it's going to
be or exactly how to get a hold of it
yes yeah returning returning to the
semiconductor business uh or fat
business uh there's been a major shift
in the supplier base for Semiconductor
Fab from the United States and in
particular from a valley here to uh the
Far East
um is is that a trend that's going to
continue or is Intel and other
semiconductors houses uh doing something
to Foster uh thinking of The Rebirth of
the equipment in particular yes the fat
equipment uh we're trying to again this
is an industry initiative in semitec
where
uniquely we have some government support
and support by some 14 semiconductor
manufacturers that now the budget of
something over 200 million dollars a
year most of which is devoted to trying
to make our U.S equipment industry
viable some key pieces have been lost
you know the lithography equipment in
particular we lost our position on very
strongly
uh
the U.S industry has a real problem and
it is tremendously fragmented it's a lot
of little companies they tend to be one
product companies an engineer has a good
idea gets support sets up a company
builds one product
uh
if we decide we want to use the product
you know we have factories in four
different states in Israel and
we probably need the the product that
all of those places at once we need
service we have a very difficult time
depending on these small one product uh
companies for those things
uh
I think the this is a problem because as
we get further and further away from the
new equipment it'll be tougher and
tougher to stay technologically
competitive so we would certainly like
to see us we'd like to see frankly a
more agglomerated industry maybe a half
a dozen fairly major companies that took
on the various pieces of equipment with
small companies maybe getting started
and joining the bigger companies you
know looking at it from my personal
point of view to really get them up to
critical mass so they can service
our needs and also can stay alive during
the downturns in the industry because if
the semiconductor industry is cyclical
you know we go up and down
the equipment suppliers are the
derivative of that
and uh you know their business goes to
zero when uh when ours goes down and
they only start selling to us again we
start growing again so it's a they have
to have considerable staying power to
stay in those businesses and it tends to
be a lot of companies get established on
the upcycle and a lot of them disappear
on the down cycle which is a waste of a
lot of energy
but caring King just a little further it
looks it seems to me that the small
company model that you're talking about
is the one in which innovation occurs in
a large company model while it has the
staying power and the resources doesn't
innovate or innovates much more slowly
and how do you maintain the sort of
growth that we're seeing without that uh
maybe a model that is something like the
way the the drug companies and the
biotechnology industry are working where
you get these Innovative little
companies getting started then they get
Partnerships with the bigger companies
who take a license to make the products
in a certain area and something like
that there's no question that uh
the little companies are a lot better at
exploiting new ideas there's been that
Gateway in the semiconductor industry as
well as in the equipment industry uh and
there are a lot of good reasons for that
you know when you don't have anything
else to do but invent you invent if
you've got a big business to take care
of uh that is pretty high on your
priority and uh it slows down some of
the invention The Invention may go on
but the company doesn't necessarily take
advantage of it it's often likely to
walk out the door and appear as a
Macintosh rather than a something else
yes
what what role do you see HD HDTV
playing and do you think that big
government initiatives on that are
called for do you think they'll produce
anything do you think the whole things
are
um a big boondoggle what's going to
happen oh boy uh
I think HDTV was the wrong definition of
the problem
uh
in the first place uh there's not a U.S
company you know a significant U.S
company that wants to be in the HDTV
business per se it's a consumer
electronics product that all the big
companies been getting out of
so there's not a U.S player to take that
on and the other hand the way computers
are evolving
they're going to look like HDTV with
more memory down the road and uh there
are basic technologies that I would like
to see strengthened in the U.S you know
the the high resolution display
technology is something I really think
we're going to suffer significantly by
not having a major participation in uh
that's the principal one I see there but
there are probably some other
Technologies and they're not related to
the TV part of it at all it's just a
information display information
processing and I think in particular the
the way the electronics Industry went
after Washington on HDTV was a mistake
uh they were asking for something they
were likely to get and they didn't
really have the infrastructure in place
to do anything with it if they had
gotten it
so it
collectively we're not Beyond running
off half cocked to do something like
that but the US overall really has a
problem there and that uh
we are very poor at bringing
Technologies to the U.S that already
exists someplace else
we can hang on reasonably tenaciously to
something we already have and you know
lose it slowly
but
I don't want to sound this defeated but
for us to go back now and say hey we're
going to be major players in high
resolution Liquid Crystal color displays
or something where there are half a
dozen Japanese companies with a
significant lead most of us don't have
the stomach to take that on I'd rather
find someplace else where they're not
yet in order to tackle a new business
and I think we're going to have to get
over that and learn how to go after all
the technologies that are necessary in
the areas we want to play but it's going
to take a while for business to change
to the point where it's willing to do
that and some of those things are tied
up with the cost of capital and how
patient your investors are a lot of
other things but it's also a basic
inclination on the part of the US
industry
okay I'll take one right here in front
modern microelectronics has made life a
whole lot easier in a lot of ways
calculators do our arithmetic for us
word processors double check our
spelling cash registers compute change
and so forth is there a downside to that
are we all turning stupid as a result
I've forgotten how to multiply a lot of
Clerks I've met have forgotten how to
compute change spelling Checkers are
making people forget how to spell is
that something you worry about
I don't worry about it at all but I have
the other problem it takes me four times
long to balance my checkbook with the
computer that used to take me by hand
but I think uh you know knowing how to
do long division was an important skill
when I was in school but I don't see why
everybody ought to have to learn how to
do that now
if you can get it out of a computer
that's fine as long as the basic
principles are understood by somebody
[Music]
one more question there yeah
okay you mentioned the high cost of
maintaining competitive process
technology if you consider the timeline
to develop the next generation of
processing technology what phases in
that development cycle are the best ones
to focus on to for improvement to reduce
the time to develop that technology
uh
what one is stuck with in developing
these Technologies to a significant
extent is how many information turns you
can get that is you get a process about
developed you want to start a wafer take
it all the way through to the end and
look at that and see what you have to
change to go back again and the cycle
time for the technology is pretty long
so you may have to do these things as
you know three or four information turns
so uh if you can look at ways to turn
that quicker
you can speed up the development quite a
bit
it's an area we put a lot of energy in
on and there's still quite a bit more to
do
uh also you want to minimize the number
of end-to-end turns you need in order to
get it so we do we call short Loops you
know little areas where you can locally
try to optimize it so you don't have to
wait for this thing to go all the way
through I think those are probably the
greatest leverage points that we have
okay well thank you
[Applause]